[Music]
the women in our parents generation
they were more into femininity you know
what i mean
because i think you would just look
great in a dress but i mean if you were
pretty much done actually thank you if
it's cool i'm just going to snag these
leftovers
i don't even know how you do it
do it dating people
no no
you do not need a man okay
so don't play the games just be you
straight out the gate do you live around
here
because i live on aisle six
that was terrible
it was kind of terrible
what's his instagram i want to stalk a
little bit you just have one say what
yeah oh no see that's
that's shady let's play a game tell me
something you don't want me to know i
hate this okay
i put all our hopes of finding happiness
through someone else yeah
girl you all digmatized and i haven't
even seen this dude
what's going on i'm gonna tell you but
you're gonna freak out
no this isn't happening
yeah it's happening
no games not what you wanted
it's about giving
giving yourself over to somebody
[Music]
becoming one forever
that's love
it's a straight girl's fantasy come true
right
[Music]
you